from June 8 people arriving in the UK by
train ferry or plane will have to self
isolate for 14 days they'll also have to
give details of where they'll be staying
and can expect a visit from authorities
will be doing spot checks anyone caught
flouting the rules faces a fine of up to
a thousand pounds there will be some
exceptions truck drivers medical workers
and people entering from the Republic of
Ireland will not have to isolate the
move comes just as many other European
countries begin to loosen travel
restrictions now we are past the peak of
this virus we must take steps to guard
against imported cases tricking a
resurgence of this deadly disease and as
a transmission rate across the United
Kingdom Falls and the number of
travelers arriving in the UK begins to
increase imported cases could begin to
pose a larger and increased threat
airlines in the UK warned this could be
the final nail in the coffin for an
industry already struggling to survive
through the crisis some say the effects
will be far wider reaching it will be
devastating not just for the aviation
sector I think we'll see 10 mm of
redundancies coming through from
airports and airlines in the UK but more
devastating for our manufacturing and
tourism sectors that rely on aviation
we've already seen 9000 redundancies at
rolls-royce last week we're likely to
see more coming like that and we risk
having this health epidemic becoming an
unemployment epidemic
the government says it will review the
new rule every three weeks after it
comes into force and for more on this we
are joined now by DW correspondent Bill
get mass in London because this
quarantine actually going to be set up
and enforced
well everybody arriving to the UK has to
give a residential address now that will
probably make it very very difficult for
business travelers but it has to be a
residential address all the details are
passed on to the local authorities and
then public health officials might come
around and do spot checks and if they do
find anybody who is not quarantine who
is not inside then there's a hefty fine
up to a thousand pounds so that really
is a lot of money and that will deter
people for sure and is there any idea
about how damaging this measure might be
to the economy in general well we know
that business groups are very very
worried they are saying it's going to
put people off coming to the UK a
manufacturing group has said it was
isolationist and you can imagine that it
really makes it very very hard for
business travelers to come into the UK
could possibly stop more or less
business traveling into the UK however
the public at large he has always been
very very cautious and they have always
been very supportive of the lockdown so
it might be that there is some sort of
disconnect here between what the
business community are saying and what
the public are supporting and why has
the British government waited until now
to implement this any idea well the
British government have said that in the
beginning of the crisis that they say
the cases of the virus rising into the
UK so it wouldn't have made much
difference if people had come from
outside and also brought the virus in
now however it's a different picture
right now they say that we're seeing the
number of cases dropping quite sharply
and so then now it would actually make a
difference and they are very worried
about the risk of a second of a second
peak while the number of cases how
been dropping and the lockdown has shown
its effect however they also say that
they're keeping this under review and
with all the pushback that they are
getting who knows how long this measure
how long this quarantine will really
stay in place in the UK
okay DW correspondent bill Kath mass in
London thanks for that